hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his treaties on anger in book one
Seneca is going to briefly but very
richly consider a very important
question is anger in accordance with
nature this is a very important concept
for the stoics but it also is something
that you know we use as a reference
point in our own culture and people did
in earlier times so you know when people
do things wrong we sometimes justify it
or at least excuse it by saying oh
that's human nature people are just not
particularly good they're prone to doing
bad things to being tempted to losing
their temper and saying this or this the
way of the world right and Seneca wants
to resist that he wants to say no no
that's wrong and he tells us we need to
consider this question and he says we
can figure out whether anger is in
accord with nature
this is a really key concept and he says
that it's going to be very evident or
clear Manifesto it'll sort of show
itself to us if we do something that we
need to do which is to consider the
human person closely if we think about
what it is to be a human being so in
latency homonym and now notice that that
is not you know man that is human beings
in general in specsarimus right so you
could say if we inspect if we want to
use a very close word to this if we
inspect the Human Condition the human
being as such now there's something
really important to point out about this
before we go on the stoic conception of
nature is you know the world is a
totality it's is connected together by
causes things have their determinate
natures and so being in accordance with
nature means in part being in accordance
with the way things work
but
human nature is somewhat different than
other animate animal
Natures in that we have rationality and
not just a capacity for rationality we
have reason as a matter of fact Seneca
will say at other points that anger only
exists in creatures that have reason
which would be us I mean there are other
creatures for the stoics that have
reason but those would be like you know
the gods and we don't have to worry
about them getting angry
we human beings we can get angry but
in a way we're not living up to our
nature because our nature as the stoics
understand it our distinctive human
nature
is the good human nature that we often
don't completely have but we should be
working towards you could think of it as
our full potential what it is to be a
fully actualized human being now if we
think about it that way then we're going
to see that anger really is not
something appropriate to the human being
it's not in accordance with human nature
he says what is milder when its mental
condition is not warped right so a human
being when we are thinking things
through when we are being rational we
are very gentle we are mild we don't get
angry with each other or other animals
or the weather conditions or pick
whatever else it is that you want so
there's this contrast between the good
developed human being and anger because
he says what on the other hand is
crueler than anger so we've got mildness
cruelty one is good one is bad right one
is human nature one is the deformation
of human nature he goes on as well what
is more inclined to love others
than a human being human beings have a
greater capacity for love for affection
than the other animals do
what is more hostile however than anger
so once again we see a contrast love
hostility or hatred being an enemy to
somebody human nature anger you're
starting to see the pattern here I hope
he says the human being is born to give
and to receive assistance that's that's
part of how we work together as a
species anger on the other hand is
inclined to destroy right the one wants
to form associations the other two
secede to remove itself from
associations human beings gather
together work together anger is the
opposite it breaks us apart so you see
you know very important distinctions
there he goes on as well the one wants
to be of benefit the other to do harm
the one wants to Aid even strangers the
other to us salt even the nearest
and dearest so anger is ready to break
the bonds that hold us together human
nature it when it's really human nature
and not just a deformed kind of human
being
is aiming at helping other people even
those who we don't know so
if you put it this way then you know
it's it's really not compatible getting
angry with our human nature and and you
could think of anger as one of the ways
in which we screw up our human nature we
by you know acting in angry ways and you
know having an angry culture we prevent
people from really having a realization
of their human nature he goes on as well
and he says
um
human beings are prepared even to
sacrifice themselves for the sake of
other Advantage anger is prepared to
plunge into danger
provided it pulls the other person down
isn't that a remarkable contrast so then
he says you know
does anyone show greater ignorance of
the nature of things it's a mistake to
not realize that the human being is
Nature's Best optimal and most
polishimo creation or work
Opus right so as that he says
um you know
ascribing anger this beastial
destructive Vice to Nature's best and
most polished creation shows that the
person doesn't know what they're talking
about they are mistaken about the very
nature of human beings and how nature
works
he points out a couple other Reflections
that we might want to consider as well
he tells us that anger is hungry or
desirous Avida you know it's it's uh
very strongly wanting punishment poenam
and
um it's he calls it a desire or a lost
there but he also uses
uh in in other places and so he says
anger as I said is hungry for payback
the presence of this lust in a human
being's utterly peaceful breast in no
way
Accords with nature so precisely because
of what anger is looking for it
shouldn't have a place in our nature a
nature again that should be developed
towards the good and then he goes on a
little bit more and he says what is
human life supposed to be about it is
constituted by the translation here is
the harmonious exchange of benefits
right so benefits benefica is and
Concord or Harmony Concordia and mutual
affection is the thing that is tying us
together
um you know a pact of mutual assistance
not by just fear but by Mutual affection
or you could even say mutual love Mutual
Amore right so a love for other human
beings this is supposed to be what is
holding us to together not the fear of
other people's anger or even other
people fearing our anger if we happen to
transgress against them there is one
thing that he says all of this is
contained in in one main
passage but a little bit after that I'm
bringing this to a kind of close he says
a human being's nature then doesn't seek
Payback right seeking payback poinai
oddpeten so and you might say it once
again well wait a second whenever I
screw up people get angry at me clearly
it is human nature and he says no no no
that's screwed up human nature that's
not good human nature so he says it
follows
that anger itself
is not in accord with nature and he
actually says there in accord with human
nature since it does seek payback this
very seeking of payback means that quite
literally seeking payback is not as he
says human nature not total Holiness
right the nature of a human being nor is
it in accordance
that human nature
as well so we should view anger as a
kind of
aberration it is indeed something that
does arise in us because of our
constitution our nature you know you
could say it arises within the social
world but from the stoic perspective
anger is always reflective of something
going wrong within not just the society
or the relationship but within the
person who's gotten angry as well in a
certain way they are deforming human
nature by the very fact of losing their
temper becoming angry in the first place
and the more that we get angry the more
that we're going to screw up our human
nature rather than realizing the
potential of it which we ought to be
doing